good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the site second Lord
now many moviegoers would attribute the
director as the storyteller of the film
and while it is true that the vision of
a movie is shaped by a director that
vision can only come together through
the talents of hundreds of people with
whom the director collaborates tonight
this room is not only full of brilliant
technicians engineers and artists but
also storytellers storytellers who help
decide if the hair on a creatures head
should be wavy or Strength's red or blue
storytellers who understand that if a
camera move can evoke a certain emotion
they create a rig that offers that
unique direction storytellers who know
the importance of maintaining the same
color information from the camera all
the way to the theater and build the
technology to achieve it because at the
core of what you do when you are working
countless hours typing code testing
hardware and connecting hydraulics you
are helping tell the stories tonight's
story is about fifty nine individuals
who have advanced the art and science of
motion pictures and we honor them in
recognition of their work and yes I said
59 so let's get a move on
a lot of winners here tonight it's
beautiful the room of winning room of
winners some losers but sometimes the
director has to get that shot a shot
that follows characters up a long set of
winding stairs or a shot that drops the
camera two stories vertically between
windows the challenge is trying to jam a
bulky crane or long arm jib into a small
physical space guys you know get my mind
out of the gutter please
sorry for innuendo Peter Braun from mad
solve that problem with the tower cam
twin peak this camera rig is a portable
telescoping and remote-controlled camera
elevator that moves through spaces no
larger than the camera itself it can be
operated using a foot pedal or even an
iPhone this invention now achieves
previously impossible shot and has been
used in major films like the help Casino
Royale and most recently in the
oscar-nominated the grand Budapest hotel
for the concept and development of the
tower cam twin peak the Academy presents
the technical achievement award to Peter
brought
Wow good evening
I'd like to thank the Academy Board of
Governors for the honor of being warded
since about 40 years I'm fascinated by
the philosophy of the moving camera
which consequently shaped the identity
of my company m80
the fantastic team back home in Berlin
and I well we are really mad about
technology there are also great people
outside my company who are mentor
advisor and friend like pork and mercy
who passed away in 2010 Paul invented
the Academy Award
Academy awarded snork camera he was a
real inspiration to me then I like to
thank Andy Romanov a good companion who
was an early believer in the tower cam
and who introduced the system to the
u.s. movie industry my special greetings
go to this year's Oscar nominated tower
cam users the directors Wes Anderson VIN
vendors and the DOP Robert Newman who
were great to work with thank you all
for sharing this very special moment
with me goodbye and auf wiedersehen